hey david you talk about undecided
voters
who the hell could possibly be undecided
right now
about trump versus biden i agree with
the sentiment i've said before
almost verbatim who the hell could be
undecided right now
only if you've not been paying attention
right could you be undecided at this
point and that indeed is the case
if you look at who are number one swing
voters
and number two who is undecided right
now
what you find is that the undecideds and
swing voters tend to be
younger centrist to center right
less engaged in politics they aren't
actually paying attention so
for example 72 percent of voters
who are 65 or older have decided for
sure they know who they're going to vote
for
among 18 to 29 year olds only 47
were decided as of a few weeks ago
that's crazy but it makes sense
in from the standpoint of if you don't
know that much about what's going on
you're more likely to say i don't know
who i'm going to vote for
or whether i'm going to vote it is
people who are paying less attention
it is people who are less informed if
you are remotely informed
and you are a likely voter you voted
before or you're sure that you're going
to vote
it's tough to be undecided right now
we've had almost four years now
of impossibly dramatic differences
between what donald trump has done and
how he has governed
and what a joe biden presidency would
mean
to the united states now the other
question about undecideds is a lot of
undecideds don't think it's that
important
whether one candidate or the other
candidate wins
in other words when you ask all voters
whether it matters who wins 82 percent
to 92 percent say that it matters
when you ask these swing and undecided
voters
does it matter who wins only two-thirds
believe that it matters so
you start to put together a picture of
the undecided voter tends to be younger
ideologically they are moderate to
center right
they aren't paying much attention and
they don't think that the
consequences actually matter that much
that makes sense
if you fall under those categories it
follows logically i don't agree with
those points of view
but it follows logically that you might
say
maybe maybe trump may be biden those who
are politically engaged have
overwhelmingly been decided for a long
time
those who have voted in the past have
been overwhelmingly decided for a long
time
and um in terms of issues one other
interesting tidbit
is that people who are still undecided
today or as of about
two weeks ago not only are they more
uninformed
they tend to vote based on their gut
feeling of how the economy is doing
and their gut feeling more generally
that
tracks sadly with someone
who could be bamboozled essentially
tricked into voting for donald trump and
that's what's
very very scary and why i am repeating
and hammering on and harping on we need
every vote
we've got to run up the vote in the blue
states we've got to get as many possible
votes
in red states even if they are states
that biden will certainly lose
don't assume anything whatsoever because
gut
feeling about the economy is exactly
who's being targeted when trump says
biggest job growth in one month ever
well yeah
after record losses right those are the
folks that go i don't know it just kind
of
sounds like things are pretty good the
stock market looks okay
this is why they pour money into the
stock market to reach
those exact voters